and you know gradually more and more of  my siblings signed on and a few of them  didn't and i've spoken to them about  that  too and i i respect that decision as  well  um but i mean in terms of like a family  meeting  not really but um but there was  there was communication and  interestingly the the documentary has  led to  greater communication between us as a  result i think which is interesting  may i ask why you were surprised that  they signed on  i think mostly because  um this isn't i mean and this is  something that  i think was mentioned in the documentary  that we never talked about  it and i mean we wouldn't talk about it  to each other  so talking about it publicly  [Music]  was just i mean it was just  it just seemed absolutely  incomprehensible  you